you're so confident so sure of yourself
but when you were just starting my mom
your mom my mom what'd she do for you
when I was nine years old and opened the
door for an elderly woman at a
McDonald's
she reacted as if I won the Nobel Peace
Prize
well my mom did was super smart she
overreacted on everything that I was
doing that was a good human trait and
she held me accountable for things that
didn't matter like grades my mom built
huge self-esteem in me and I feel like
the biggest reason I am who I am today
to everybody is because I feel so guilty
and so grateful for what she did for me
that I want to do it for everybody else
which is guess what you suck at a ton of
[__] good so does everybody else you're
also probably pretty [__] rad at
something try as many things as possible
until you figure out what you're rad at
and you like and go [__] do that for
the rest of your life and stop giving
the [__] about everybody else
thanks she is
[Applause]